Alex welcome to the show Alex this is
Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where I
deconstruct world class performers of
all sorts of types ranging from
billionaire investors to chess prodigies
to actors to writers to athletes and
everything in between
in this episode we have a real treat and
it's a two-part episode with Alex
Blumberg who is very well known as a
producer for this american life co-host
of Planet Money and also the co-founder
of gimlet media which has currently two
blockbuster podcasts startup and
reply-all and in the first part which
you're currently listening to we are
going to talk to Alex about all sorts of
aspects of the business of storytelling
the art of storytelling including gear
that he uses etc the second part is
going to be an excerpt from a class that
he taught on creativeLIVE calm normally
costs about $100 and I advised that
company so I was able to pull out about
a half hour of his teaching a class
about the art of the interview crafting
the perfect question etc that is part
two I implore you to listen to both I
really enjoyed this and without further
ado please enjoy Alex Blumberg
Alex welcome to the show great to be
here thanks for having me and I have to
start off because we have been
scheduling and I know you're racing to
get a show out the door does it ever get
any easier I really hope so
is it has been yeah I mean it's just
been I mean it's sort of an insane
project but I'm doing which is which is
trying to you know create a regularly
occurring documentary podcast about a
company that's starting up well at the
same time trying to start that company
so it's been sort of like I know it's
because both of them are sort of
full-time jobs so yeah and how do you
how do you balance because I've listened
to every episode of startup and have
followed it very closely for a whole
host of reasons how do you balance the
real time documentary nature of the show
with planning say an editorial calendar
and actually having things locked and
loaded and ready to go in advance
oh I don't balance it that's the problem
like that we don't have things locked
and loaded and ready to go in advance
like we don't we were editing the we
were we just finished editing this
week's episode this morning and then we
just tracked it that's why I was a
little late with you I was tracking it
in the studio today and then it'll go up
tonight so that's how close to the wire
we are I mean we're just we're you know
things are and you'll hear this episode
is all about it's all about burnout Wow
I was wondering I was wondering when
that episode would come yeah yeah
because there's a period where where I
think there's a period in a company's
life where people are like well this is
just the start up this is the start of
experience and then there's a point at
which maybe like probably right about
around where we are at four or five
months into it or you're like it's a
startup but it shouldn't be this hard
and so so we sort of realizing like we
have to we had to we have to we have to
change some things have to add some more
support and part of it's just like you
just don't know you know like I
no I mean you know you don't know what's
possible and so so we started out I
think we just didn't have enough
capacity to do what we were trying to do
and what is what is your current team
look like if well first question is what
is tracking I'm still a novice at this
and I have a ton of questions but oh
what is tracking exact so yeah so
tracking so when when you're doing sort
of a documentary style podcast which is
sort of the kinds that we do where where
you're we have a script and so what I'll
do is I'll go out and I'll gather tape
in the field then I'll record in
different conversations with people and
then I will edit those down and so I
have a bunch of sort of like basically
selects tape tape that I've gathered and
I've edited down and cut so it's like
you know I'll have like uh maybe like
you know 25 minutes of edited tape and
then what I have to do is stitch that
together with a script and so I'll write
the script and then we'll do edits on
that script and so I'll read it aloud in
the office we'll all sit around a table
sort of like a table read I guess I'll
sit around I'll read my script and um
play the tape that I've cut from the
computer where it's supposed to go in
the story and then people give us notes
on the script and sort of say this part
was dragging and this part should come
earlier and this part you can just
totally get right up it's boring
whatever and then you rewrite and
rewrite and rewrite and then finally you
get to the final script and then you go
into the studio and track it and that's
when you actually just lay down your
your voice tracks and then those all get
mixed together into the final product
got it and the the the actual reviewing
of the tape so you capture a lot of
interview obviously and in one of the
episodes of startup you had one of your
employees reviewing those tapes do you
personally review those tapes or do you
have someone to a first pass and attempt
to pull out the interesting stuff it
goes both ways I mean usually I've been
the one getting the tape so I have heard
it yeah because I was there you know I
was there right you know with the you
know with the microphone and the
recorder but you usually it's my
producer who actually does a first pass
through and pulls all the all the
selects got it
and what are what are the criteria for
pulling the selects what what is what
makes something worth being in the show
I think what you're asking Tim is what
makes good tape we just which is that's
right that's exactly what am i that's
the question that has consumed my my
life for the past 20 years so I have an
answer for you so I think I think when
you know one of the things that there's
a couple things that you're looking for
when you're going through the tape so
because I have a script because I'm
narrating it I can sort of say pretty
much all the all the basic information
usually better than anybody that I'm
talking to so what I'm going for our
specific moments when I'm talking to
people I'm going for specific moments
that have some kind of deep emotional
resonance or where something very live
and unexpected has happened or where
there is just very authentic emotion has
been expressed and those are the moments
that I go for it's almost sort of like
if I'm talking to somebody about
whatever I don't know just to borrow an
example from my planet many days bond
prices what I don't want is somebody
talking about bond prices I want
somebody expressing some sort of emotion
about it if that's possible you know
because I can do all the nuts and bolts
you know sort of information transfer
and so what you're looking for in your
energy subjects is something something
that that you can't provide yourself
some unique perspective the other thing
that you're going for the other thing so
that's one whole category of good tape
is sort of like emotionally resonant you
know emotionally authentic or something
where something interesting or
unexpected has happened sort of in the
moment the other category is somebody
just telling you a really good yarn like
a really good narrative and so that's
the other thing that we look for is sort
of like sort of at this American Life we
had a term for this we just call it an
anecdote but what we really meant was a
little story and so like like just for
an example if I start to talk to you and
I say you know Tim this morning I was
leaving my house I was walked out the
door and I was like I looked up in the
sky and I saw something that I couldn't
believe like you
here what I said next right that's very
unfulfilling story is so that's the
story like we are hard-wired to be like
a c1 sequence of action another sequence
of action and it's gonna build towards
something we want to hear what it's
building toward and if I say to you I
saw something I couldn't believe a cloud
you'd be like that's a boring ass story
but if I said you know a UFO then you're
like oh that's an interesting story so
so but but the but the the mechanics of
it the fact that it's a story that has a
beginning and it's sort of and it has
like a narrative progression and sort of
you know sort of rising action human
beings I think are sort of hardwired to
want to pay attention to that that's
that's what we've been telling each
other for you know 40,000 years and so
um so those are the other things you're
going for is like people telling you
stories and the the process I'm so
fascinated because I'm struggling with
this myself the process of putting
together an episode especially when you
currently have the the real time aspect
of it which seems to complicate matters
tremendously if how many people do you
currently have works working on each
episode of let's just say startup and
what are their roles yeah I mean so
that's the thing about this stuff is
that it's like it's so much more time
consuming then then then the other sort
of main kind of podcast which is out
there which is a straight interview
podcast like which we were doing which
is which are also like all these
elements can be possible in those kinds
of podcasts as well and so what we're
doing is sort of sort of like I go back
and forth like is this insane to be
spending all this time producing 20
minutes of one kind of podcast when
another kind of podcast you could
produce in 20 minutes you know what I
mean and and so what we have is we have
so right now on startup it's just me and
my producer Katelyn and then another
employee Lisa who's who's going to be
producing the second season of startup
that's not quite enough startup comes
out every two weeks so we can bear and
and because I've been doing this for so
long and I've internalist so much of
this stuff like I'm
probably more productive at it than than
somebody else but so we can bear we're
not quite getting by with that but we
would definitely need you know we need
some more
we need another body or two for sure and
aside from the producer you also have an
engineer who does yes supposed to clean
up and that type of thing yes alright so
we have yeah so so on staff is it's me
and Caitlin our producer and and Lisa
and then we also have other people on
staff who can help with the edit which
is a really really important part of it
so so there's other people so then we'll
usually have one or two other people
sitting in to do the edit so where I sit
around and do the table read they'll
give me notes and sort of say this part
was slow this part wasn't so that's a
really important thing and then we and
then we we also outsource our transcript
so we have people logging all that tape
so that it's easier to go through so we
have people providing transcripts of the
tape and then we have an engineer who
mixes the episode which is you know
basically everything from doing all
sorts of things that I don't understand
like putting compression on it and
making it sound really good but also
just sort of like putting it all
together making it sound good making the
levels right all that stuff got it and
the one thing that struck me about reply
all the other show that I've been
listening to from from gilt media is was
listening to the launch of that and how
the hosts decided to join forces with
you and one of the things I mentioned
was wanting you as an editor or having
you run to them run to and from the two
shows working with them as an editor
does that primarily mean that you're
working on the script and reviewing the
transcripts or what what what is what
are you doing as an editor yeah I mean I
think what I think of myself as and I
think one of the reasons that I started
this company I I think my primary skill
like the probably if I had to say it
like here's the thing that I am best at
it is at being an editor and and being
an editor means that you like and the
way I think about it it's sort of like
from the beginning it's basically being
a collaborator with the hosts with the
talent to getting you know
the best show that you can get and so I
try to so you know like what that means
is that when we have a weekly story
meaning for reply all where we'll sit
around for you know we'll talk for two
hours like for an hour about you know
what are the stories that they want to
want to pursue and we'll think about
interesting angles to go at that story
with will decide if there if it's worth
it or not and then we'll sort of plan
like okay who do we want to talk to who
would be some interesting people to talk
to in this story what questions do we
want to ask them like the questions are
really important like if you go out and
you ask and you don't ask the right
questions you can come back with nothing
you can come back with no good tape and
so you have to sort of design your
questions so that you're sort of giving
yourself a higher chance than average of
getting good tape and then so we do all
that and then when they do when they
come back and they write the script then
I'll go through the script with them and
usually we do at least one pass but
sometimes two and maybe even three
passes depending on how tricky a story
is where we'll really dive in deep and
sort of get into the language and sort
of say this you know you're saying this
but it's not quite right and so it's
just it's I mean it's I think when
people see it for the first time from
the outside it's like you they can't
believe how much how much actual work
goes into into the making of this stuff
and I'm not sure you know I'd like one
of the big questions is sort of like how
much of that work is actually necessary
work and how much of that work is like
are we are we spinning our wheels but my
contention has been that like to really
like you know if you look at the very
top of the charts and iTunes like a lot
of those shows have that that amount of
labor embedded in the programs that
they're putting out like I come from
This American Life which is where I
learned all this stuff and like you know
but there's even more sort of editing
and production work that goes into
making those shows and I know certainly
cereal they were working on that for a
year at least so so the so it you know
so yeah so I so I think it's related but
I'm not sure
oh it's massive I mean I I was I was
blown away and not terribly surprised
when I heard that cereal had a team
working on it for a year yeah
prior to the launch didn't surprise me
at all I mean as someone who's a very
plotting writer himself it didn't really
surprise me how did you how did you
decide well actually before before I
jump away from the editing what do you
do as an editor differently from other
people i well I think is you're clearly
you're clearly very good at I mean the
output of the shows reflects that so the
question is you know maybe why aren't
other people better editors or what do
you do differently I think I think it is
a bunch of things like so I first I
think I learn I think this American life
was a real editing shop and I think it
was it's a pretty special place like in
that IRA is really he's a really great
editor but he's also very encouraging to
people to sort of do their own thing
like it's his show but he really
encourages you to do your own thing
within that show so every when I worked
there every story that I thought I that
I wanted to do that I could that I could
sort of make a good case for I was able
to do and I was able to write it myself
so I think part of being a good editor
is being sort of is wanting to encourage
others to sort of like is having that
feeling that like if if we're working on
this together I can take my ego feels
like I got some of the credit because I
was in there from the beginning but
you're also happy to share the credit
with the person who's doing the story so
I think part of it is goes back to that
sort of how do I think of myself as an
editor and and at this American Life it
was like sort of an elevated job and
then I think partly it's sort of like
when I got to NPR I realized that like
the conception of the job was you know
your reporter goes out they come back
and then they play you a story and
you're basically it's not the time it's
the time you know you make a couple
suggestions I didn't understand this
part and understand that part but you're
not like thinking big about like well
what's the idea that we're trying to go
towards with this
what's the new thing we're trying to say
and so I think partly also what makes a
good editor is getting in there from the
beginning
and talking with the reporters about
what are we trying to say what you know
what what's the interesting thing what's
the new thing that we're going for here
if we're doing a story that's been done
a lot like I don't know politics or
homelessness or whatever it is like
something that you've heard about in the
news a lot race like how are we gonna
talk about it in a different way in a
new way in a surprising way and a lot of
like you know half the f you know a lot
of the work that makes a story good goes
into the very beginning and I think
that's a lot of editors don't think
about their jobs that way and I think
that's that that's why it's and so I
think that's that helps me you know if
I'm in there from the beginning and sort
of talking about it it's easier the
other thing one other thing that I think
about about editing and just quickly is
that like one of the biggest jobs of the
editor is just being paying attention to
your own boredom you know I think people
get people who get into journalism get
in because like I'm interested in the
world and I have a natural curiosity and
I want to satisfy that curiosity but you
know you got a you're still like you've
got to keep keep your audience
interested and and and the editor can
help do that like the editor if you you
have to be curious about the world that
you also have to know like you have as
this sense and you're listening to your
boredom it's something that I had to
learn to do but once I did it's really
helpful what are the symptoms of boredom
so I I know that might sound funny but
what are the thing what are these
symptoms of boredom that maybe you
didn't listen to in the early days as
much well I think you try to sort of
like if there's some if somebody reads
something that is like it's something
that you like that you work together
they're sitting across the table from
you and they read something that doesn't
is like maybe like a sort of a boring
sentence or they've come through a
boring thing or somebody's talking on
tape and you don't quite know what
they're saying or what the point is
because you like the person and because
you know you're a human being with
decent human emotions you'll you'll
you'll be trying to think that like oh
we'll probably what the person was
saying
this and so therefore you know though
that all makes sense because I you you
make up for the reporter who's who's
doing the read and it's and that's good
like that's decent human behavior to try
to like sort of meet somebody halfway
and be understanding and empathetic to
what they're saying but there's
something that happens on the radio or
on audio when you're listening you don't
the listener doesn't do that and so you
have to train yourself out of that
instinct to make up to sort of fill in
the gaps with what people are saying so
one one sign is just the sort of glimmer
of like wait I'm confused here and it's
a very very it's often at the back of
your head you don't quite get it you
don't have to pay attention to it cuz
you sorta get what's going on but
there's like some like there's some
question your mind is like is that the
thing that's going on that I think is I
think it is but it's a very very slight
you have to train that to sort of come
to the beginning of your brain to the
head to the forefront of your brain that
feeling because the minute that feeling
happens you know this is a spot that
needs to be edited and the other part is
just sort of like you know you you you
you know you find yourself drifting and
in an edit and if you're drifting in an
edit it's not it's not your fault it's
theirs you know I mean that's harsh
that's what you have to do if I'm
reading through and somebody who's
listening to my story is drifting that
is my fault
I have to keep you from drifting so and
so the same thing is if the shoes on the
other foot then this is the same thing
is true if you're the editor your job is
not to be engaged their job is to engage
you and and so and so you so the minute
you feel yourself drifting that's
another section that needs to be edited
no definitely and you brought up things
being unclear or hard to understand when
I found as a writer when I send things
to my friends who are writers to have
them proof of chapter if I ask them to
indicate if I first asked them to
indicate what they liked and disliked
they might try to appease me or feel
badly about hurting my feelings so I
always start with just point out what
isn't clear usually yields a much better
result because it's they don't feel like
they're being as judgmental towards me
personally right I always find that a
really helpful place to start and that's
even more important in audio because
audio is like you you can't go back and
reread
you know what I mean but now in the age
of on-demand audio you can go back this
is true or back in the radio days when
there is literally no mechanism to go
back and read listen but but you and so
what happens is the minute you're
listening if you're confused you're like
wait what was that thing and you've been
Trent and you try to figure in your
brain what was the thing that was
confusing you and then your brain has
taken its eye off the ball basically and
not listen to the next sentence right
coming out and then it's like a train
wreck like you never catch up you know
what I mean so one moment of confusion
definitely can utterly destroy an
otherwise beautiful story you know and
so you have to be on you have to be on
you know a special garden about that in
in audio I think particularly what what
does a producer do so this this has come
up quite a bit you mentioned you have a
producer for instance what what is the
what does what does for start-up in
particular what does the producer do
what is their job and it's one of those
job it's those words like manager which
is like wait would what's a manager you
know you yeah so a producer I think is
like also has many meanings but in my
case what a producer does so my producer
helps me think through the interviews
I'm gonna do often will listen back
through the tape transcribe the tape
sometimes or make sure that it's
transcribed she will pull the
interesting pieces of tape you know
usually we'll consult about it but then
she'll go and actually produce a session
in the editing software that we use that
has the the polls that that we want
she'll also think through like how to
structure each episode and all sorts of
other things like when like every when I
was at this mecca knife I was my job was
producer that was what I recalled and
and and you basically helped build the
story with the reporter you know you're
really sort of like a partner in the
creation of the story and the reporters
voice is doing it and the reporter is
often sort of like writing and and and
in some cases finalizing the writing in
some cases really doing most of the
writing but really you're a team and and
structuring the story is so important
in audio especially I think just because
you can get so confused easily so so so
generally what the producers are in the
audio world are they're experts at sort
of structuring the story like how do you
what how does the story begin and what
are the emotional moments that we're
leading to and how do we contextualise
those moments with script so often when
I was a producer at this American Life
we'd be working with writers who were
really good writers who had not done
that much audio and often what I would
do is I would cut the tape and then I
would have and then we would meet and I
would just sort of talk them through
like so we would have gone out and done
a bunch of interviews I would cut down
to the moments that we were gonna use
and then we'd get back in the room and
I'd tell them like okay here's how I
think you can start and here's what I
think you want to say to start it up and
then we're gonna go to this piece of
tape and this is the first piece of tape
we're gonna use and it introduces this
character in the story and then from
there you're gonna want to write
something like this and sometimes I
would have dummy language in there and I
would basically provide a road map for
the for the reporter or the writer they
would sort of lead through the tape and
get to a finished piece so that's that's
that's got it I thought they do yeah and
in at at gimel media which is of course
a much smaller operation than this
American Life who's handling releases
and all that kind of stuff yeah the
producer would be doing that as well so
the so producers sort of like do sort of
the high level conceptual structuring
stuff and then they they also sort of
like transcribe cape and they also sort
of like handle all the details and make
sure the plane tickets are purchased and
you know you know various people have
been set up and booked him to various
studios and all that sort of stuff with
with I know we're getting into some
nitty-gritty stuff but I'm so fascinated
by and then we're gonna go kind of
broader picture the what type of editing
software do you use Pro Tools Pro Tools
yeah and with with reply-all for
instance which is is perhaps a little
more can be planned a little more in
advance how from the initial idea pitch
meeting to the finished episode how long
does that currently take and how far out
have you planned already not necessarily
gathering all
in phone doing the interviews but
decided on the subject matter for
episodes well I mean we not as far
planned out as we want to be you know we
have we have we're we have things on the
calendar going out maybe a month or
month and a half but you know it's it's
always a race every week to get
everything done so as especially as
you'll hear on the next episode of
startup but but but and and and so some
of those are just ideas some of those
are like you know there's all that all
the tape is in and it's been edited and
we and we just have to sort of like
wrangle it into shape so yeah so but I
would say that we don't have anything
we've never had our goal is to sort of
get to a point where we can have
everything where we can have we can be a
week ahead like we can have next week's
episode in the can this week like done
recorded the ads put in everything done
mix the music in and I would say we're
several months away from that goal like
we just we just need to get better at it
and build that muscle
what tool what tools do you guys
currently use I of course take I'm an
avid sort of hyper graphic note-taker
I'm sharp be mentioned in one of the
episodes what type of tools do you guys
use for organizing all this stuff
besides Pro Tools what are the the you
know the software or the the whiteboard
I mean what do you guys use we use
actual whiteboards we use we have like
little whiteboards that float around the
office that have sort of like the
checklist of everything that needs to be
done every episode you know sort of like
just sort of like there's the basic
stuff that you forget like you know did
we did we get the ad copy correct we get
the do we email all the people that we
write the copy for the web that we all
that stuff you know
did we get the list of songs that were
using in the episodes that we can put
them on the website and then and then we
use and then we kill we have a lot of we
do a lot of collaborations so the most
of the stuff that we write our scripts
are all written in a Google Doc and we
have multiple people editing through the
Google Doc that really changed my world
when that came around and that's
fantastic
you know we slack at the office like the
younger guys do I don't really know how
to use it really we we but there's I
think those are the main ones like the
Google Google Docs are sort of the main
thing that we use to sort of collaborate
right on and then and then actual
whiteboards we schedule stuff through
Google Calendar awesome do you use any
kind of project management software like
a base camp or a sauna or Trello or
anything like that I have I have worked
on projects where I've used base camp
before like when we did our website
design we use Basecamp with the design
team that was designing the the the
website and that was really useful like
I find Basecamp to be useful for like
distributed teams when I was at Planet
Money we did this big sort of crazy
project where we followed a t-shirt
around the world as it got made and we
did this sort of elaborate web
interactive website about the project we
had all these videos and stuff like that
and that was like a couple different
teams one in New York one in DC and we
use Basecamp for that project as well
and that was really helpful on a day to
day basis I don't I don't I don't use it
as much just cuz you know it's pretty
simple what we're doing the bulk of our
work is sort of like you know managing
you know wrangling tape and writing
scripts that's sort of like that's the
day-to-day that's every what I'm doing
every day is that essentially what do
you what are you guys currently use for
capturing tape in the field we use in
terms of equipment we use flash card
recorders and and you know nice-nice
microphones we use we use these tascam
tascam recorders some of you Sony's but
just there you know pretty nice you know
broadcast-quality you know sort of
they're not the nicest but they're the
pretty nice ones and then we have a nice
mics mm-hmm know what type of if you
know offhand and I I'm involved with
creative lives so I managed to grab a
PDF of your some of your gear I don't
know if it's changed since then
yeah but I'm an advisor for creative
live and by the way it's I'm going to
I'll link to it in the show notes for
everyone but the I've been very
impressed with the class so what we'll
come back to thanks but it's just just
the the master class stand in asking
questions so of course I've performance
anxiety right now yeah that's why that's
why I decided to swing completely the
opposite direction that's very boring
hyper specific tax but no questions I
mean the concrete details that's another
one that people forget like people go to
broad and I think what's often
interesting is the the nuts and bolts of
people's process so these like I'm less
you know like I think often I'll ask
these exact kind of questions like sort
of like on a day-to-day basis like what
are you when are you actually doing like
I like I did yeah I do these Squarespace
I do these ads right and um right we're
just interview somebody in the company
about what their job is like and the
company that's you know that sponsoring
so I guess we're gonna do one of these
ads later but but my my my goal there is
just to try to find one sort of like I
call it like a like a vivid moment a
moment where it's sort of like you know
like if into one time I found myself
talking to a treasurer of one company
and I was like talking and like I wasn't
getting very much vivid stuff I was like
sort of like what's it like to be a
treasurer and wasn't getting very much
and and finally I was like dude what's
the you know do you actually sign your
name on the checks and he was like we
have a non a signer but sometimes I
actually sign the checks and then we got
into a discussion of sort of where he
sits when he signs the checks and how he
signs them and how much time how long it
takes
does he block it off in his calendar and
that was like by far the best moment of
the interview because it felt all the
sudden you were like you actually it
felt real you know and you got a real
sense of sort of like the
details of this guy's life so I'm off
were these could these kind of crank
these questions okay well I'm gonna
follow on with with some some digging
then the I noticed in the list of
equipment and again I'll link to all
this and the show notes for people the
that you have a boom mic and I have for
instance a a zoom recorder h4n and I
have another model that's of to to
follow up questions is there any reason
you chose the tascam over the zoom or
anything else and then the second is
what do you use the boom for because I'm
just when I'm sitting down with someone
I find the these these handheld you know
H the the zoom recorders for instance
work quite well by themselves they work
even better with a LOF mic or something
like that or just a handheld stage stage
mic connected with XLR s what do you use
the boom mic for I mean I can give you a
lot of BS about it but the truth is I
don't
it's like habit basically like these are
the microphones that we started using at
this American Life when I first got
there I didn't know anything about audio
I am NOT a super technical li like I
know a lot about like the story
structure I don't know very I don't know
I know exactly what I need to know about
recording equipment I'm not super tech
savvy that way and so so partly it's
just sort of like that's the those are
the ones we use and I got used to them
and I can hear this island right now I
understand like when I'm out in the
field I know exactly what I need to do
with that particular mic to get the
exact sound that I want to get and I
don't have to like mess around with
something new the one thing that I will
say that I think the reason so the
tascam that was just that was the
recommendation that I read on a website
night and I bought it and and it's
worked for me although there's certain
things that I don't love about it so so
I feel like you're you're fine whatever
works for you you're fine fine with
their the so the mic is more important
than the recorder and and my so that was
so part of it is just sort of habit part
of it the real part I guess is is that I
as long as it's a directional mic what
I'm trying to do often is get intimate
sounding you know conversations
and so if you have an omnidirectional
mic which is the mics the mic recording
pattern is picking up from all around
the whole field of you know where you're
recording you know just you you you just
have to be you have to worry a little
bit more about placement and you just
you sometimes don't get it does n't feel
like they're as present whereas if
you're using one of these sort of
unidirectional boom mics like the one I
use it's really weird like when you
point it at somebody you can hear them
and when you point it away you really
don't hear them very well it really
drowns out all the surrounding sound and
so what that means is you get this
pretty nice very very intimate sound and
then if you and then if you're in a in a
place where life lots of other stuff is
happening around and you want to
document the fact that you're out in the
field and there's a rodeo going on
behind you or whatever you can just when
you're done with the interview you just
point the mic at the rodeo and get that
ambience and then you can just use it as
an ambience bed so so I like so I like
the intimacy that you get with like with
it with a nice tight boom mic what no
that makes perfect sense I what numbers
do you check on a daily or weekly basis
and not to beat a dead horse but this do
you guys use Charpy did you end up using
that and what other what other numbers
besides just straightforward kind of
revenue numbers for sponsors what kind
of stuff do you guys check mmm I mean if
anything I again I'm I'm I'm I was
obsessively checking our SoundCloud
numbers cuz that we host on soundcloud
and so I could see so SoundCloud feeds
our iTunes so every time somebody's any
- anytime somebody who subscribed to
start up it downloads to their phone
that registers as a play on soundcloud
so SoundCloud was documenting was sort
of capturing both the the people who are
listening streaming it through the web
or through our website or whatever and
the people who were downloading it onto
their phones through iTunes or some
other pod catcher so it was a one-stop
shop for our for our listening numbers
basically and so I would check that and
that was pretty much everything that I
checked I didn't you know I know PJ and
Alex
that was the reply all are much more
tech-savvy and much more you know sort
of aware of what's going on and so
everyone said well I'll ask them sort of
like what are they looking at and they
look at truck beat a lot but but we
haven't I don't look at that that much
got it so so I want to rewind the clock
a little bit and just I'm looking at
looking at your bio and it says you've
worked as a social worker a caterer an
eighth grade science teacher and a
graduate level journalism professor tell
me the story of how you got to radio if
you could yeah the story I guess the
story starts I was in I was in I was a
teacher I taught eighth grade science
and I was I did that for four years and
I this was in Chicago how old were you
at how old were your the time around
what time yeah this is in my America mid
mid to late 20s so starting at like
maybe like 24 to the time I was 28 or
something like that 28 29 I was teacher
and um and I had basically it starts
like I'd always been interested in this
kind of I guess what you'd call
long-form narrative nonfiction you know
like I had read you know a couple
magazines since the time I was in high
school like I liked The New Yorker
magazine and I like Harper's Magazine
and and I like these kind of and I would
read these books of like you know sort
of like you know Joseph Mitchell who's
this sort of famous olds you know
nonfiction writer and I would read you
know EB White and stuff like that
John Hershey you know the guy who wrote
him so I was at her see her she write
and uh and so I was I was into that kind
of stuff and then I would um but I never
for some reason and I was pretty I was
pretty good student and I like you know
I did I did okay but somehow I'd never
occurred to me that I could actually do
that as
for a living I don't and I don't know
why like I really don't know why I
thought I just somehow thought that like
the people who did that were some sort
of different world of people that like I
would never be able to access that world
and like now it's a ridic it like the
thought that like you know an upper
middle class Jewish kid could ever make
it in the media world like wait you know
of course how could that happen I don't
know why I was so I don't know why I was
so why I think was just like a profound
lack of I didn't know anybody who had
ever done that I grew up in Cincinnati
Ohio which was like you know not not
super provincial but just you know
certainly not a media capital and so you
know people who succeeded became doctors
and lawyers and that was sort of it so
so anyway so then but then I started
dating a girl from New York when I was
in Chicago and she that was more of
where media happened and she knew people
who were actually getting jobs at
magazines sounds like getting a job at a
magazine is an actual thing and then we
dated for a while we did for like four
or five years and then she eventually
broke up with me which was like one of
the more profound experiences of my life
and that was really what kicked me in
the ass and sort of was like and that
happened right you know in my late 20s
and that was when I was like okay well
if if you're gonna like I don't know
what you're you know I was telling
myself like it was basically spite like
I was worried that her plan was to go
back to New York and go to film school
and I was just like terrified that she
was gonna become a famous director and I
was gonna be sitting around supervising
recess and so it was really that that
was like okay you gotta you gotta try to
you know this has been this dream that
you haven't really admitted to yourself
so you should just try to do it so so I
started trying to freelance and I had an
internship at Harper's Magazine that I
had that I successfully applied to and
got and over the summer in between and
be between one of those years when I was
teaching
and then I eventually through Harper's I
met I got a I got a job as the
administrative assistant at this
American Life which was you know the
public radio program and podcast that
was just starting this is back in the
like I guess back in 97 October of 97
when I got that internship and when I
got the administrative assistant job and
it it had been in the air on the air I
think two years at that point and had
become sort of you know had already made
a name for itself but wasn't you know
the you know beast that had that it is
today
the podcast kingmaker that it is today
so so that's where that's that's that
and that got me started
you know I as I was an administrative
assistant I sort of learned on the job
as like four of us back then it was IRA
three producers and me and what a
perfect perfect timing man had a great
job yeah just the four of you that's
amazing yeah and I learned a lot on the
job but then I eventually but then you
know eventually so so but I was the
administrative assistant right I was
like the one writing you know answering
the mail and sort of like running to the
post office and doing all the stuff that
needed to be done and because we were so
short-staffed back then and because like
you know IRA really had no idea what he
was getting himself into like a weekly
hour of documentary radio we're like the
standards are there than anybody has
ever had before like he is a
perfectionist you know and I learned a
lot about the value of being a
perfectionist from from him so but like
you know the fact that he was trying to
produce that with you know three
producers who didn't really know what
they were doing because it nobody knew
what they were doing you know like he
was he's trying to invent it so it was
all hands on deck and so occasionally I
would get to produce stuff or like help
with the editorial side of things and so
I learned on the job but then there came
a moment where I was like I'd produced
this I'd actually produced semi so like
not what I would call producing now but
I'd assisted in the creation of one of
one of our big early shows which was an
hour-long documentary about Harold
Washington and the first black mayor of
Chicago and and it was sort of a hit you
know in in the early days and
I came in after and had been you notice
the bear to produce and I was working
all kinds of crazy hours and I came in
after it aired the day that Monday after
it aired and you fully expecting like
okay now I succeeded I passed this test
and now I'm gonna be made a producer and
I said I wanted you know what would what
do you think was he gonna make me
producer knew he was like no I can't I
don't I don't have money to make your
producer I don't have a position open
and I need an administrative assistant
and I was like oh well if you ever did
have money and the position open would
you hire me and he was like I don't know
probably not cuz you don't have the
experience still that I need you know
there's other people now who have that
experience I was like well what do I
need to get that experience and he said
well I don't know you probably should
quit and start freelancing and I don't
think he thought and now as a CEO of my
own company I have this experience all
the time we're out I'll sort of think
out loud and I don't realize that you
are like hanging on every word I'm sure
that was what happened with him but to
me I was like okay well you've just
given me the map of how I want to get my
dream job so I'm gonna quit so so I put
in my notice and I arranged like a loan
from my parents to help me live for the
year like 10 grand I was like how if you
give me 10 grand in lieu of graduate
school I will gonna make it as a
freelance writer and and we and I you
know I did I just tried to freelance and
I got stories and magazines and art and
newspapers and stuff like that and I
continue to do radio and then a year and
half later I'd sort of built a little
freelance career for myself and which
was going pretty well and then there was
finally an opening at this American life
and things had been going so well that I
actually was like I'm not going to apply
for that because now I've doing this
other thing and then finally somebody
was like this he was your dream job
right and I was like yeah I guess I was
and then I applied and then immediately
I was like I really want this job so and
then I got it so that was that was that
was how that happened Wow
so when you were freelancing the how did
he see her the writing that you were
doing did you find the writing took off
more so than the radio were they taking
off in tandem did the radio start to
outpace the writing how did that how did
that go during your year of real
well one of the things that I learned
and that one of the biggest lessons I
learned is never ever return your key
card so I still have my key card from
WBEZ
coming up why good radio doesn't
necessarily apply to television the
value of perfectionism and the good and
bad habits that Alex picked up from this
American life in IR glass but first a
word from our sponsors
the Tim Ferriss show is brought to you
by on it I have used on it products for
years if you look in my kitchen in my
garage you will find alpha brain
chewable melatonin for resetting my
clock when I'm traveling kettlebells
battle ropes maces steel gloves
sounds like a torture chamber and it
kind of is it's a torture chamber for
self-improvement and you can see all of
my favorite gear at on its calm forward
slash Tim that's onn IT comm forward
slash Tim and you can also get a
discount on any supplements food
products I like hemp force I like alpha
bran check it all out on it comm forward
slash Tim the Tim Ferriss shows also
brought to you by 99designs 99designs is
your one-stop shop for anything graphic
design related you need a logo you need
a website you need a business card or
anything else you get an original design
from designers around the world who
submit drafts for you to review you are
happy or you get your money back and I
have used 99 designs for book cover
ideas for the 4-hour body which went to
number one New York Times for banner ads
and you can check out some of my actual
competitions at 99designs dot-com
forward slash Tim you can also get a
free $99 upgrade if you want to give it
a shot that's 99designs calm
forward-slash Tim and now back to the
show
did the radio start to outpace the
writing how did that how did that go
during your year of freelancing well one
of the things that I learned that one of
the biggest lessons I learned is never
ever return your key card so I still had
my key card from WBEZ the radio station
where I've been working and so I would I
could come in and I was I had some
freelance projects that I was still
working on at that at that station so
they hired me to help produce this like
poetry series they were doing and and I
and so I was picking up freelance work
both in radio and on the writing side
and it was pretty equal like I did a big
radio documentary and I did something
for show called the savvy traveler which
was a travel show back then so within
the public radio world there was like
there was enough stuff that needed to be
done and not that many people who were
like so free to do it that I can pick up
you know sort of work at that point as
well so it was about half and half
got it and how did you come to then
co-found Planet Money because I mean and
what was the timeline between getting
landing that dream job as producer and
getting to Planet Money so that was I
guess there was a year I mean though
there was there was a decade in between
getting the job I got the job in 99 and
then Planet Money started in 2009 and
one of the nice things about working at
this American Life was that like the job
was constantly changing as I was there
so I never had day at like I never got
bored like you know I started and I sort
of took a long time the learning curve
is pretty steep to get good at producing
documentary radio so the first couple of
years I was just trying to get my head
above water and figure out how this
stuff worked and what people were
talking about in these edits and you
know how to become better at recognizing
good moments and all that stuff and then
and then and then you know 9/11 was a
I mean it sounds cheesy and tried to say
about like 9/11 sort of changed the
focus of the show quite a bit we became
you know we did a couple of shows on
9/11 and then we we just got I think we
think it made us a little bit more we'd
always been serious journalistically but
I think it like felt like we were able
to tell kinds of stories that were both
sort of journalistic and and human in a
way that like felt like it filled a
niche a little bit so so we did a lot of
reporting on that and on the war and we
went to an aircraft carrier so that sort
of changed and then we did a TV show in
there too so we did this big TV show for
a Showtime and I was an executive
producer on the TV show so then I was
like spending you know three or four
years learning how to do TV which was a
whole other huge learning curve and man
did we get our asses handed to us there
like we thought we were storytelling
experts then we got into this new medium
and were like nothing we know works give
some examples because yeah I'd love some
examples yeah well I mean it's a lot or
an explanation of why it doesn't work
why why didn't it translate well
everything that I laid out to you about
like what's good tape you know what
you're going for in a radio interview
like that stuff doesn't apply to TV so
like what I'm often you know you can
make an amazing radio story out of one
or two people telling a story that
happened to them in the past like well
you know one of my first I won a big
award called the Third Coast audio who
were in at this American Life which was
essentially two people a brother and a
sister talking about a story that
happened to them you know 60 years ago
it was just the two of them talking and
we intercut them and we put in a little
bit of script and it was like one of the
most moving stories that I've ever
produced and like that's death on
television you can't watch people
telling a story about something that
happened a long time ago something about
it just does not work and we would try
to produce these things and we'd be
watching them and we'd be like bored out
of our skulls because there's just like
that you you just need so much more
visual information than just watching
people
you know watching people talk so that
was one of the big lessons is sort of
like it made me realize like oh TV
that's why that's why reality television
is so is so big like you you can do it
you can produce a story from the past
but it's but to do it you have to just
feel you have to give people something
to watch and so you have to invent an
entire visual story to go along with the
the story that any person is telling and
that's just and that's really expensive
so if you look at like an arrow Morris
documentary or something like that where
like there's that one where he will be
an example of of one of like the stops
before the fog of war was one that I'm
so that's the one where he interviews
who's the interview um what's his name
the guy from yet I haven't seen the
movie okay he interviewed Imus general
from Vietnam who is one of the ones that
sort of like was came under a lot of
criticism he and it's a lot about like
what went on back then you know in
Vietnam and if you watch the movie net
and I watch that movie around this time
and I was like oh look at what he did
like he filled every second every frame
with like invented imagery that he had
that he had to invent and come up with
and it's so time-consuming and so
expensive versus sounds like sounds like
man on wire yes and man I'm wire exactly
the same type of thing and if you watch
that movie now they have to do so much
work to keep the screen covered with
interesting things to watch versus if
you just take you know your average
reality show or you've got like two
family members fighting with each other
that's the that's the narrative crack in
visual terms like we are hard-wired to
watch that stuff it's so much cheaper
yes turn the camera on and you watch two
people fighting and you want to watch it
that's why TV is the way it is because
that's what we want to watch you know we
don't want to watch yeah you know we
want to watch things moving on-screen so
so it was really it was really hard and
so we had to think way to think entirely
differently we had to think entirely
visually like
what's an interesting visual story
versus an interesting audio story yeah
and I suggest anyone listening who
enjoys reality television not learn too
much about how its produced because it
will it will shatter the veneer I
remember I I was I was talking to this
guy who's worked on a bunch of reality
shows you would recognize and he said
have you ever noticed how many of the
arguments happened with people standing
up in the kitchen and someone's always
mixing something do you think that
happens naturally they are always
arguing in the kitchen and someone's
just absent mindedly stirring something
that we never really find out about i I
wanted to come back to perfectionism
because you mentioned you you learn the
benefits of working with a perfectionist
or maybe you said being a perfectionist
and you also mentioned the New Yorker so
I had I had a chance very I was very
fortunate to have the chance to study
nonfiction writing for a semester with
John McPhee who's a staff writer for The
New Yorker and just a phenomenal
phenomenal writer with the the greatest
attention to detail and structure of
anyone I've ever met
but I'd be curious to hear sort of what
what did you learn from working with
with IRA what are the benefits of being
a perfectionist or working for one I
think I think it's basically it just it
what I learned is that a lot of it is is
just about the effort you put in and
it's not about like you have to have you
know you have to have a creative brain
and like part of it is that you know you
just you just sort of born with I guess
partly you're you're you're sort of born
with part of it at least but like
watching IRA like sort of like work a
lot of times he's just he just keeps
thinking about it longer than other
people keep thinking about it and then
eventually he comes up with an idea
that's good and it just made me realize
like that's how people get to good ideas
if they go through a lot of bad ideas
first and that there's not really like
occasionally a good idea comes to you
first if you're lucky
but like usually it only comes after a
lot of bad
yes and so what being a perfectionist is
is sort of just like putting it a little
bit more time to think through the level
one or the level two ideas and try to
get to something that's a little bit
deeper and I think that's why we do as
many edits as we do because often what
happens in an edit is you'll take a bad
idea and you'll make it into a good idea
over the course of several edits and
you'll have an idea that's in a script
that's sort of like that's just getting
you from one point to another point and
then you'll be like you know what this
is like it's like this and you'll come
up with a good metaphor and then you'll
be able to call that's a good metaphor
to put in this part of the script it'll
really make it sing and then eventually
you'll get to a part where you're like
oh it feels like a revelation will now
happen at this point in the piece
whereas before it was just moving from
one you know from one thing that
happened to the next so so I think that
I learned that and then are there any
examples I'm sorry go ahead yeah I'm
gonna come back and I was just gonna ask
you are there any examples of me perhaps
from start up and reply all but it could
be from previous shows of a specific bad
idea that was turned into a good idea
well it became a good idea yeah I mean
it happens every single time so I'm
trying to think of one that I could
share that was like that's like that's
easy enough to explain let me think for
one more second I don't know this might
be hard to do sure we can we can we can
come back to it I wanna yeah pick up
where you left off with me yeah yeah let
me think about yeah I can come up with
an example for you but okay
are there any habits that you picked up
from IRA or the This American Life team
otherwise that you you still have any
particular any particular working habits
but either either but um so the good
habit that I picked out is that I picked
up is sort of like like being committed
to excellence like that is something
that I learned and I learned it from IRA
like I think he really just hate
have something go out when it could have
been better and if he had an idea of how
to make it better he would always almost
always try to make it better and still
does and that's like that was that was
and I was not that way I was sort of
like the kind of guy who was like yeah
that's good enough you know and um and I
what I realized is that and and I and I
but I I that was sort of a I think being
that way is a little bit of a dodge or a
rationalization or an emotional sort of
like thing you do to sort of like not
actually try to make things good you
know because trying to make things good
is scary and you might fail and people
might say it sucks and we all know that
and so we all like find our ways of
rationalizing with it and rationalizing
and that's and that's what I was doing I
was like it doesn't matter it's okay and
so working with IRA like I was like I
know this is a guy who really cares
about making it good and of all the
things to care about in the world that's
one of the better ones you know just to
try to make something excellent like
there's a lot of things you can care
about and that's a good thing to care
about so I learned that from him and I
there's a certain comfort with crisis
that he had that I'm afraid were off on
me also but I don't think is a good
thing I think that's a bad thing kid can
you give any any any particular moment
come to mind and yeah yeah well it's
limited I mean I think I mean he just
the show would was always like Everett
for the entire time I worked at this
American Life it was always like up
until the very last minute it was it was
getting produced and edited and you know
it was always like it was you know you
would be shocked they probably like 20
to 30 percent of the time you were like
is it even gonna go up and that's crazy
you know over like 15 that's a lot of
you like 30 or 30 percent of the time
are we gonna make it this time
I mean and and then in a certain point I
was like oh yeah we're always gonna make
it because we always make it but still
it's like it's always right up into the
right up into the last minute and and
it's better now it's way better now and
and like they've forgotten like
processes in place and stuff but
and part of it is just audios real-time
so even if you've been doing it for a
long time you just can never quite get
your head around how long it takes but
part of it is a but part of it is just
sort of like he's comfortable with that
and I think in a certain way it focused
his mind I think and I think it also
focuses my mind I think like I've
noticed myself doing like this this
episode recently like you know I'm the
one who's writing it and I've got a
whole bunch of other things that I have
to do and on top of writing the script
for this week's episode and it's like I
sit down I try to think but I'm like
worried about this thing and I'm worried
about that thing and I and in the back
of my mind in this bad part that I
learned I think is but it's gonna come
it'll I still have you know you know
Monday morning at 5:00 a.m. I'll just
get up early you know I still have that
in in my in the back of my mind and then
and at that point I'll have no choice
and I will have to make it good and so
I'll just leave it till that moment and
I don't think that's not good and I like
what it does is it drags everybody else
into your crisis and so my you know
Caitlyn my producer is like dragged into
my way of dealing my way of managing my
time and my way of sort of trying to
make things good and that's I don't
think I don't think she likes it and I
didn't like it when I was a producer
like I felt like why is he saving
everything till the last minute
and I'm doing my exact same thing you
know - - yeah so yeah that's that's
because I learned all those you know I
had 20 years of learning like it always
comes out you know it's fine though it's
bad it's bad you know so yeah I've I've
learned that that I've developed a
similar level of comfort with crisis and
last-minute turnarounds and I fell from
personal experience learned the hard way
that that is a very fast way to burn
people out who haven't been conditioned
and how you can lose really good talent
unfortunately the the commitment to
excellence are there any stories that
come
mind of particular time for instance you
handed you you pass something on to IRA
that you thought was good enough and he
was like no not good enough and gave it
back to you did that happen yeah oh I
mean all the time like every single
thing I ever read or did was it was net
I never and this is not an exaggeration
I don't think anybody ever in the
history of this American life has ever
had this happen where though I'll read a
draft even if it's the second or third
draft and it'll be like and the and the
answer is like all right it's it's all
done there's always a new tweak and
there's always something that can make
it better and often there's like big
thoughts and so and and again like and
in the beginning it would sting a little
bit it would be like I got I just want
to do one thing where it's like done and
I did it right I took it really
personally like I'm not doing it right
and then it was only over time that I
realized that like no you're not nobody
does it right like the the first draft
always sucks always for everybody and
and and and you just got to get over
yourself a little bit like it's not it's
not about you and your ego it's just
about trying to make it better and then
and then I realized there was like there
was like that's really useful to be able
to have that muscle of like sort of like
okay I trust myself enough that I'm not
a complete idiot but that it's always
you know and I can be made better by
other people's input in ideas
that's essentially what an edit is and
that's also a really good way of going
through the world you know
isten is to try to be open to what
people are telling you so that was a
really I think that's you know the
commandment excellence means being
comfortable hurting people's feelings
and being comfortable having right
anything's hurt and to try to take the
feelings out of it and and and just talk
about like what the thing you're trying
to do is
and that that's that was really useful
to learn and would would IRA ever just
say this isn't good enough give it
another shot or was it always very
specific feedback oh it's always very
specific feedback always very specific
got it I'd do it again
better like that's that sort of like
yeah and that's also I think what being
a good editor is because he's such a he
was such a master of like the form that
he he could tell you what was wrong and
he could tell you like this isn't
working for this reason and often it's
like it's like really stupid little
things like so for example I can give
you an example of this like from from
this current episode of startup that we
just did we it's all about burnout and
basically we made the stupid decision to
it's coming out today I think it'll be
up by the time this post so you can
people can listen to it but it's it was
it basically we you know we we had this
we had this situation where like the
hosts of reply all were working they
ended up they were working late sort of
like every day for like weeks and this
was over the holidays when we made the
stupid decision to try to put up a show
on Christmas and on New Year's Eve I
don't know why we didn't take the week
off but we didn't I think we felt like
we were just knew we were just starting
so it wasn't was too early to take time
off or something so they were crashing
trying to get these shows up on
Christmas Eve and on New Year's Eve and
the shows weren't coming together very
well and they were just working really
really late and then one of our when
Lisa started recording conversations
with them about like how they were
feeling they were feeling super burned
out and it was it's really good it's
really good tape and so that's what the
episode is about and we were scripting
the episode and I started by and this
all happened it came to a head when I
was out of town I was in San Francisco
where my where my wife's family lives
and we brought the kids out there over
the holidays but I was like it's
supposed to be sort of a vacation but I
was basically working the whole time but
there was a day or two that I didn't
work and so I started the story by
saying like all this happened while I
was on vacation and we
like one line but that one line put this
whole like and the story was pretty good
and we were just telling the story and
we're like we're playing all this pretty
entertaining tape of people talking
about how burnt-out they were and how
their whole feelings about their jobs
had changed and it's all very real very
raw very entertaining but something
about me saying that I was on vacation
had this whole skull D tone all the way
through it which is sort of like I leave
for one day and the whole place goes to
hell sort of which was not intended at
all but that was it had that feeling it
sort of cast the entire episode and this
sort of like unpleasant light and and so
that's why I'm saying like it was in we
were doing these edits and we were like
this should be good like the tape should
be good but when we were listening we
were like this I have this I don't like
it it's making me feel bad not good and
uh and and it was and it wasn't until I
was like one of our Starly but I think
one of our other employees put put her
finger out and she was like it's that
that's the that's the thing that's
making it feel bad is that is that the
just that line in the beginning where
you just sort of a give it colors the
whole way you're hearing this thing and
so we just recraft at the beginning to
be about like this transition in a
startups life where you go from trying
to raise the money to all of a sudden
you're running me running the
organization right and they're two
totally different jobs and like this is
an episode about how we were trying to
manage the second phase of actually
running the company and dealing with our
employees and so that gave it a much
better context basically to listen to
the story in its how far into the
episode did you put your finger on that
and and fix it so from the from the
first kind of pitch meeting or decision
to make the episode about burnout how
what what amount of time elapsed before
you're like oh okay that's the that's
this issue we need to fix it was
probably like we did the first we did
this edit and we actually put together a
rough mix which we all listened to over
the weekend and that was the one we were
all like freaking out because it wasn't
working at all and we're like coming how
this is a stinker and the rough mix is
like missing music it's just tape strung
together
it's a little bit more than that because
it was like we we had a really good guy
doing it but yes it was like the levels
weren't all mastered and everything like
that we knew that we were gonna come do
you do scratch do you do like scratch
audio for the script as well or no we
had recorded the script we had recorded
the script so we done the whole thing
like we it was it is this was actually
more work than we normally do normally
this would have been a second edit but
we were like sort of behind the guns we
were like well maybe this will work so
but it didn't so so it was essentially
like a second edit and we did the second
edit and we realized that it wasn't
working and then it was over the weekend
basically that we were thinking about it
and then this morning was when we sort
of like I came in and rewrote rewrote
the the top based on sort of notes that
Starly had given me last night at 10:00
and there's a couple other things that
were happening in the episode that were
also sort of like robbing it of its of
its power that we changed as well but uh
but yeah it took it was probably like a
couple days of sort of like sitting and
thinking with it that's the other thing
that I learned from IRA also about
excellence like excellence is just
tricks you know it's just managing your
time and your expectations because
there's this panic where you do like
when I first heard the rough mix I was
panicked because I was like this is bad
this is a bad show but like but I have
seen but then I had to remember like
okay but you thought some part of it was
good in the beginning and you have to go
back and remember well was the part that
was good and there's some reason that
something that was good has now become
bad there's something that you're doing
wrong you have to fix it's not a it's
not a crisis you know what I mean it's
just sort of like it's a problem to
solve and you know and that's it's just
hard to remember that sometimes like you
just get and I think that's what you
know with experience you start to
realize like you've done it enough times
like you've taken something that was bad
and you've made it good that you realize
like it's it's it did it's not the end
of the world or it's not even it's not
like something that can't be fixed cuz
that's the feeling you feel like oh my
god there's nothing to be done
like the thing that I thought was good
is bad so I'd love to talk about
asked just a few more long-form
questions a couple of fast ones and then
we can wrap up but the I want to talk
about turning a bad situation into a
good one very specifically I'd love to
chat about startup episode number nine
we made a mistake so and about being it
attacked and villainized so maybe just
for context if you could explain to
people what that mistake was and then
I'd love to to dig into that a little
bit yeah so we we do these ads on the
show there we have two ads in the middle
of the show and we we produce our ads
documentary-style so what we try to do
is we just try to interview people
either in the company or users of the
company about their own real experiences
and we and we turn those into little 45
two-minute long segments for the fur as
our advertisements and one of our
sponsors was Squarespace and the website
company and what we were doing is we
were talking to different Squarespace
users about their Squarespace sites and
we'd found this kid this lovely charming
little boy who had a Squarespace site
that he used for Minecraft and we've
done this interview with him and it
would have been lovely and and then we
put it up and we realized that we had
never told him or his mother that it was
for an ad we had just a and she had the
impression that this kid was gonna be on
this American life like that her son was
gonna be on this American life and then
she got and then she heard from a friend
that it was actually used in this ad and
then she she got very upset and she went
on Twitter and was talking about it on
Twitter and she had a lot large Twitter
following and so a lot of her Twitter
followers were you know upset as well
and then we started digging into the
details and it was like a little bit
even worse because like it turned out
that the email that we'd sent to her had
sort of you know given the impression
that I did still work at this American
Life which was made it seem even
sleazier
I was just a it was a it was like a
really bad screw-up on our part that
that seemed to her of quite logically
and rightfully that had been
on purpose and an intentional deception
and I enjoyed the episode for a host of
reasons but I mean the first of first of
which is we all make mistakes the second
of which is how quickly things can
spiral or seemingly spiral out of
control with the internet social media
and how much of a crisis it can seem
like and just like you working as a
producer you know I've been sort of on
the front lines online for a good period
of time now so when when someone's like
oh like this this like parity piece came
out about your book in the New York
Times and now I'm just like huh
interesting I guess I should take a look
at it later this afternoon I don't have
like oh my god the sky is falling
everything is over response not always
which we very much had I definitely
realized that now like it was like sort
of like and there was a couple people
who were sort of visiting the office
around that time and they were like we
think you're overreacting and it was
like it just which we definitely were I
think but it definitely it did feel like
this like the company was so new and so
young and we ate and you know we've
managed to do this thing which which I
wasn't sure I was gonna be able to pull
off which was sort of like to document
making all these mistakes you know and
still have people like along for the
ride with you you know what I mean right
and like because a lot of times when you
lie times when you make mistakes you're
not at your best or your worst you know
you see you're sort of your unpleasant
side or the part of you that's sort of a
dick or whatever is sort of coming
forward and to sort of air all that and
still have people sort of on our side
and supporting the company in supporting
the show we felt like we were already
walking a tightrope and this felt like
this was going to be the thing that
knocked us off and you know definitely
and what I was curious to ask you is as
someone who's been on the documenting
side for so long looking at different
situations documenting other people's
lives
perhaps painting them not in a negative
light but in a in a neutral or
comprehensive light if you went back to
say interviewing people and covering
people for hard-hitting news or
something like that
like has your viewpoint changed or your
your feelings about that because a lot
of journalists absolve themselves of the
damage they might do to someone if it
gets a lot of clicks or a lot of views
or a lot of listens and I'm just
III know that this American life is is
at least all the episodes I've heard are
very constructive but I'm just wondering
how how you're feeling about how your
feelings as a journalist or
documentarian changed as a result of
becoming a target yourself well show
this is a bed because I was like this is
bad mix I was panicked I recorded the
script we hit record ripped as well or
no
we liked scratch audio for the screw
gonna come back do you do scratch do
dirt and everything like that and we
knew that we were gonna the levels
weren't all math it's the internet
spiral out of control wings can spiral
or seemingly it's the second of which is
how quickly first of which is we all
make mistake of reasons but I mean the
first of said for a host I enjoyed the
episode and us and an intentional
disability that had been on purpose
logically and rightful to her quite
seemed part that that really bad screw
up on our it was this it was like a year
I know it's just a made it seem even
sleazy I work at this American Life
which was not always which we've
response everything is over oh my god
the sky is falling and afternoon I don't
have the lake home I guess I should take
a look at it later the Senate's like huh
interesting look in the New York Times
and now I'm parity piece came out about
your this like when when someone's like
oh like the good period of time now so
what's on line four I've been sort of on
the front lines you know I think you
working as a producer seem like and just
allow much of a crisis at consider yeah
and given the impression that I did stop
you know her had sort of emailed that
we'd sent to us because like it turned
out that the president was like a little
bit even where all these mistakes you
know making other like to document or I
was gonna be able to pull off which was
which I wasn't sure which dude this
thing you know we've managed to do and
we ate and knew and so yeah just like
the company was so
it did feel like but it definitely
definitely where I think it which and it
was like it just we think you're
overreacting visiting the office around
that time and they're likely and there
was a couple people who are sort of eyes
that now like it was like sort of a very
much had I've definitely real fun
situations documenting looking at did
for so long from the documenting side as
someone who's been on you is Malayan
what I was curious to ask him know that
it's gonna be the thing that knocked us
off a rope and this felt like this was
like we were already walking attempting
supporting the show we felt him on our
side and supporting the kind still have
people so not to sort of air all that
coming forward and a dick or whatever is
sort of that or the part of you that's
sort of your sort of your unpleasant so
your best or your worst you know it's
just I
I know user a lot of listens and I'm
Jennifer gets a lot of clicks or a lot
of people damage they might do to
someone else absolve themselves a lot of
journal about that because aliens juror
your your feelings like has your
viewpoint change that or heartening news
or something like people and covering
people for you interviewing to say you
went back the neutral or comprehensive
light but in a in a maps painting them
not in a negative other people's lives
primes when you make mistakes you're not
ether than everything like that and we
knew that we were gonna come back do you
do scratch do you do like scratch audio
for the script as well or no we had
recorded the script we hit record a mix
I was panicked because I was like this
is bad this is a bad show yourself well
salt of becoming a target you're changed
as a return elasaur documentarian how
your feelings as a dealing about now how
you're but I'm just wondering
constructive I've heard or very at least
all the episode so that this American
life is my god the sky is falling
everything is over response not always
which we will work at this American Life
which was made it seem even sleazier I
know it's just a it was a it was like a
really bad screw-up on our part that
that seemed to her of quite logically
and rightfully that had been on purpose
because like it turned out that the
email that we'd sent to her had sort of
you know given the impression that I did
stuff in social media and how much of a
crisis it can seem like and just like
you working as a producer you know I've
been sort of on the front lines online
for a good period of time now so when
when someone's like oh like this this
like parity piece came out about your
book in the New York Times and now I'm
just like huh interesting I guess I
should take a look at it later the size
that now like it was like sort of like
and there was a couple people who are
sort of visiting the office around that
time and they were like we think you're
overreacting
and it was like it just which we
definitely were I think but it
definitely it did feel like this like
the company was so new and so young and
we ate and you know we've managed to do
this thing which which I wasn't sure I
was going to be able to pull off which
was sort of like to document making all
these mistakes you know and it was like
a little bit even were sort of your
unpleasant side or the part of you
that's sort of a dick or whatever is
sort of other people's lives
perhaps painting them not in a negative
light but in a in a in a neutral or
comprehensive light if you went back to
say interviewing people and covering
people for hard-hitting news or
something like that like has your
viewpoint changed or your your feelings
about that because a lot of journalists
absolve themselves of the damage they
might do to someone if it gets a lot of
clicks or a lot of views or a lot of
listens and I'm just I know it's at
least all the episodes I've heard are
very constructive but I'm just wondering
how how you're feeling about how your
feelings as a journalist or
documentarian changed as a result of
becoming a target yourself well show
this is a bad because I was like this is
bad mix I was panicked recorded the
script we hit record ripped as well or
no we do like scratch audio for the
screw gonna come back do you do scratch
do deeper than everything like that and
we knew that we were when you make
mistakes you're not logically and
rightful to her quite seemed part that
that really bad screw up on our it was
list it was like a year I know it's just
a made it seem even sleep
the work at this American Life which was
not always which we respond everything
is over right oh my god the sky is
falling ever that this American life is
is your best or your worst you know it's
coming forward and to sort of air all
that and still have people sort of on
our side and supporting the companies to
pray in the show we felt like we were
already walking a tightrope and this
felt like this was gonna be the thing
that knocked us off and no definitely
and what I was curious to ask you is
just like huh interesting book in The
New York Times and now I'm parity piece
came out about your this like when when
someone's like oh like the good period
of time now so what's on line four I've
been sort of on the front lines you know
I think you working as a producer seemed
like and just allow much of a crisis at
concede yet and given the impression
that I did stop you know her had sort of
email that we'd sent to us because like
it turned out that the blade that had
been on purpose as someone who's been on
all these mistakes you know making other
like to document her I was gonna be able
to pull off which was which I wasn't
sure which dude this thing you know
we've managed to do and we ate and knew
and so young just like the company was
solely it did feel like but it
definitely definitely where I think
which and it was like it just we think
you're overreacting visiting the office
around that time and they're likely and
there was a couple people who were sort
of eyes that now like it was like sort
of like I guess I should take a look at
it later the side or the part of you
that's sort of you're sort of your
unpleasant doesn't it was like a little
bit even wearing the documenting
society's are a lot of listens and I
mean if it gets a lot of clicks or a lot
of the damage they might do to someone
else absolve themselves of a lot of
journal about that because I'll endure
your your feelings like has your
viewpoint change that or hard-hitting
news or something like people and
covering people for interviewing to say
you went back in neutral or
comprehensive light but in a in a maps
painting them not in a negative other
people's lives predict or whatever is
sort of for so long it was this it was
like a really bad screw-up on our part
that that seemed
to her quite logically and rightful
items when you make mistakes you're not
easier than everything like that we knew
that we were gonna come back do you do
scratch do you do like scratch audio for
the script as well or no we had recorded
the script we hit record an X I was
panicked
Lillian what I was curious to ask you
know that it's gonna be the thing that
knocked us off my rope and this felt
like this was like we were already
walking attempting to pray in the show
we felt him on our side and supporting
the can still have people so not to sort
of air all that coming forward and your
best or your worst you know you see that
this American life is my god the sky is
falling everything is over response not
always which we work at this American
Life which was made it seem even
sleazier I know it's just a because I
was like this is bad doesn't it was like
a little bit even were sort of your
unpleasant side or the part of you that
sort of I guess I should take a look at
it later the size that now like it was
like sort of like and there was a couple
people who are sort of visiting the
office around that time and they were
like we think you're overreacting and it
was like it just which we definitely
were I think but it definitely it did
feel like this like the company was so
new and so young and we ate and you know
we've managed to do this thing which
which I wasn't sure I was gonna be able
to pull off which was sort of like to
document making all these mistakes you
know as someone who's been only that had
been on purpose because like it turned
out that the email that we'd sent to her
had sort of you know given the
impression that I did stuff in social
media and how much of a crisis it can
seem like and just like you working as a
producer addict or whatever is sort of
other people's lives
perhaps painting them not in a negative
light but in a in a in a neutral or
comprehensive light if you went back to
say interviewing people and covering
people for hard-hitting news or
something like that like has your
viewpoint changed or your your feelings
about that because a lot of journalists
absolve themselves of the damage they
might do to someone if it gets a lot of
clicks or a lot of views or a lot of
listens and I've done the documenting
aside recorded the script we hit record
ripped as well or know we like scratch
for the screwin and come back do you do
scribe dude you turd and everything like
that we knew that we were items when you
make mistakes you know logically and
rightful to her quite seemed part that
that really bad screw up on our it was a
it was like a for so long you know I've
been sort of on the front lines on line
for a good period of time now so when
when someone's like oh like this this
like parity piece came out about your
book in the New York Times and now I'm
just like huh interesting you is this is
a bad show yourself
well assault of becoming a target you're
changed as a return Allah store
documentarian how your feelings as a
juror I know it's just the made it seem
even sleazy to work at this American
Life which was not always which we
respond these they are everything is
over right oh my god the sky is falling
ever that this American life is is your
best or your worst you know it's coming
forward and to sort of air all that and
still have people sort of on our side
and supporting the companies to pray in
the show we felt like we were already
walking a tightrope and this felt like
this was gonna be the thing that knocked
us off and no definitely and what I was
curious to ask mix I was panicked like
this like the company was solely it did
feel like but it definitely definitely
were I think which and it was like it
just we think you're overreacting
visiting the office around that time and
they were like and there was a couple
people who were sort of eyes that now
like it was like sort of like I guess I
should take a look at it later the side
or the part of you that's sort of your
sort of your unpleasant doesn't it was
like a little bit even work because I
was like this is bad feeling about know
how you're but I'm just wondering
constructive I've heard are very stall
the episode just III know looking at
different situations documenting very
much had I've definitely real afternoon
I don't have the like homeless and an
intentional deception and I enjoyed the
epithelia and just allow much of a
crisis at consider and given the
impression that I did stop you know her
had sort of email that we'd sent to us
because like it turned out that the
blade that had been on purpose as
someone who's been on all these mistakes
you know
making I'd like to document or I was
gonna be able to pull off which was
which I wasn't sure which dude this
thing you know we've managed to do and
we ate and knew and so yeah seemed to
her quite logically and rightful items
when you make mistakes you know
next next time you're in San Francisco
to visit the the in-laws or the wife's
family we should put together a dinner
of some type just for just for the hell
of it I had that done that'd be a good
time like I mean who do you have people
like that that you're like oh that's
that guys doing it well she's she's
really got to go on like I do I do I do
and you know one of them is a close
friend of mine who was in your first
episode that's Chris Sacca so as as an
as an investor I've been early stage
investor in a lot of companies like
whether it be Twitter or advisor tuber
etc Evernote and Chris was one of the
very early mentors I had and he's a
close friend but he also is very very
good obviously at the early stage
startup game so it was really Mike
maples jr. initially and then Chris
Sacca and also a guy named Navarro
Vacanti are spectacularly good at what
they do and they have a myth a
methodical way of dissecting certain
types of problems and so I try to I I
enjoy learning their respective recipes
you know they're kind of algorithms that
they use for evaluating things because
they're all clearly effective but
they're also sometimes very different
which I find fascinating so in the in
the startup world since I'm not there
are people just because I'm running you
know I I have my own fledgling podcast
and then the the blog which is much more
established and so on there are people
in the and I don't really love the
content creation label but people in the
the content sphere whether it be audio
or spoke or written word or even video
and television that then I really
respect a lot you know I find what
Morgan Spurlock does very fascinating
for instance he was
kind of in front of the camera and
behind the camera but now does both
including things that make him very much
behind the scenes so yeah I mean I I
guess I've been on my own I'm sorry go
ahead
no I was I know a couple people who are
working with his company and he seems to
yeah it seems like a great you know he
seems like he's doing really a job
running yeah yeah he's a nice hub for
for where you know we're cool things can
happen yeah he's very good at
establishing rapport with just any any
group you can imagine so with you know
inside inside man I think it is I don't
think it's inside job inside man it's
and its really spit yeah it's just
incredible to see how quickly he can
establish rapport with with people so
I'm gonna ask you the UH perhaps the the
opposite of the word successful not
failure but what's the first face that
comes to mind when you think of the and
you're very nice guy so this might be
hard just hard to answer but what's
what's the first face that comes to mind
when you think of the word punchable
that could be your answer to no I'm just
trying to decide so I will tell you this
like I feel like coming from I guess
coming from the not like the nonprofit
world like where I I never had this is
the first this is my first full-time job
in the for-profit sector it's being the
CEO company since I was like a hell of a
way to a hell of a way to start and I
think and coming from the public radio
world and the nonprofit world at large
like I do think there is a way that we
we conceived of we we conceive of
ourselves as punchable in that world
like that we're like not that
need that like we need to be shielded
from this this world of profit and like
somehow that there's like a that it's
that it's that it's dangerous and it's
filled with people who will sort of eat
you for breakfast and and I think you
know I mean that's like gross
exaggeration lots and lots of people in
the nonprofit world are like you know
like this is like this is a gigantic
gigantic over generalization just so you
know but like but I do think there's
like a slight attitude that I ran into
at a public radio in other places that
like the the that were shielded in this
world from having to do you know from
like some sort of like you know angry or
sort of like you know macho or
malevolent forces in the for-profit
world and uh and that's like you know
and that that's been one of the nice
things and maybe you know who knows
maybe I'm gonna like get like my ass
kicked soon I probably will and like
I'll be like you know god I wish I was
still in the nonprofit sector or
whatever but but there was like there's
something about like just sort of going
out and being part of this sort of you
know market economy in a really really
straightforward way that's freeing and
and doesn't feel like it doesn't you
know doesn't it feels like the way it
should be and that's scary you know ya
know it makes it makes perfect sense I
mean I think that it gives you I've you
know I work with a number of nonprofits
like DonorsChoose in New York which is
run really leanly actually very much
like a for-profit in that way but the
for-profit word gives you some metrics
that are very clear to play with that
that I think can be freeing in a way
because there's there's very little and
be ambiguity about it know that metric
thing was huge for me yeah that we
didn't have like it was like sort of
decisions you didn't it's a very you
make decisions for then you end up
making decisions for all sorts of other
weird sort of arbitrary reasons so it's
like what does the director like it or
do our donors like it or you know rather
than not like do people like it right in
the world you know that people value
enough to pay for yeah
yeah definitely if now on that point
you've you've you've kind of not switch
teams it's not like they're opposing
teams but you've you've done a lot since
you you were you were first teaching
eighth grade science obviously what
would the old what would the old you say
to the new you or what would the old you
think of the new you ah the old me would
think of the new me I think it depends
on which which stage you go to but like
you know going back to like you know
sort of the college and post college
like the old me you would think would
probably think the new me was some kind
of sellout maybe I was never that like
sort of like that
strident ever but I was definitely more
strident that I am now and I definitely
would have you know and I was definitely
sort of a little bit more suspicious of
the profit motive when I was younger so
I would probably be like what you know
like what have you done with your life I
mean the old me would also be like
you're an old man and all you do is like
go and you have like these two kids that
are just you know I would have looked at
myself with horror I'm sure I haven't
seen a movie and God knows how long I
don't travel anymore you know so alright
one more question for you so if if you
could give your 20 year old self one
piece of advice what would it be
this is gonna sound corny but uh don't
be yeah I don't be so afraid you know I
think I I think I organize a lot of my
choices based on sort of what I thought
I could do rather than what I wanted to
do and I did that because I didn't want
to try to do things that I wanted to do
because I was afraid I would fail at
them so the guy organized a lot of my
life around fear for this first you know
that first decade after college and I
tell my Scott oh don't be afraid you
know go out and just like fall on your
face a little bit more it's all right
yeah that's good advice so Alex just in
closing and now you have to run where
can people find more about you about
what you're up to
well you can listen to the startup
podcast it's all right there and that's
in that's at our website gimlet Mediacom
both our shows are their startup and
reply all and you know all sorts of
stuff about our company and about me
wonderful all right Alex I will let you
get going I really enjoyed the the
master class I will put tons of links in
the show notes for everybody including
links to the shows to get the media to
the gear that you use in the field to
creative live class and and much more so
thanks so much for the time
and don't forget this is a two-part
episode with Alex and we're going to
give you a sample of that next part the
art of the interview which is a class of
his it is fantastic so we'll give you a
few minutes of that and please continue
listening but first just a short word
from our sponsors the Tim Ferriss show
is brought to you by on it I have used
on it products for years if you look in
my kitchen in my garage you will find
alpha brain chewable melatonin for
resetting my clock when I'm traveling
kettlebells battle ropes maces steel
clubs
sounds like a torture chamber and it
kind of is it's a torture chamber for
self-improvement and you can see all of
my favorite gear at on it comm forward
slash Tim that's onn IT comm forward
slash Tim and you can also get a
discount on any supplements food
products I like hemp force I like alpha
bran check it all out on it comm forward
slash Tim the Tim Ferriss show is also
brought to you by 99 designs
99 designs is your one-stop shop for
anything graphic design related you need
a logo you need a website you need a
business card or anything else you get
an original design from designers around
the world who submit drafts for you to
review you are happy or you get your
money back and I have used 99 designs
for book cover ideas for the 4-hour body
which went to number one New York Times
for banner ads and you can check out
some of my actual competitions at
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim you
can also get a free $99 upgrade if you
want to give it a shot that's 99designs
dot-com forward slash Tim and now back
to the show
so this is story that we got in this
American Life a while ago and um the
setup is that it's this actor Tate
Donovan and Tate Donovan is was a sort
of a character actor he'd been you know
sort of on a couple of different shows
but recognized it very much and then he
had a like a stint on friends and all
the sudden II was trying to get
recognized and it was really exciting
for him to be recognized because he
finally got to be the celebrity that he
always wished that he could be the
celebrity that he would have wanted to
meet before he was famous so when he got
recognized and so one and and this story
happens when one night he was out at
this Broadway show and a lot of people
were coming up to him being like hey i
saw you and he was able to like talk to
people and be very magnanimous and say
thank you so much it really means a lot
and he was like posing for pictures for
people and it was at the show it was
happening over and over and over again i
was i was i was exactly how i wanted to
be I was doing it I was doing great and
then the kid with the camera came along
this nervous kid he must been 16 years
old he's in a rented tuxedo unbelievably
like shy and awkward and he's got like
acne and he's got a camera in his hand
and underneath the marquee is his date
who is literally like a prom dress and
she's got a corsage and she's really you
know nervous and sort of clutching her
hands and he sort of comes up to me any
sort of mumbles you know something like
you know something about a picture and
I'm like I just feel for him so I'm like
oh absolutely my gosh sure no problem
like God you poor thing and and I go up
to his his girlfriend I wrap my arms
around her and I'm like hey where you
from
fantastic gonna see the play it's great
and the guy is sort of not taking the
photograph very quickly he's just sort
of staring at me and he's got his camera
his hands and it's down by is like chin
you know and and she's very stiff and
awkward and you know I don't know what
to do so I just leaned across and I kiss
her on the cheek and I'm like alright
God take the picture hurry up
you guys want to find out what happens
next
that's a story when you want to but so
what
that is the power of a good narrative so
when I talk about I'm talking about like
those two basic things you're going for
emotion and narrative we as humans are
hard-wired I believe to listen to
narrative and it's a very simple sort of
the mechanics of narrative are very
simple there's like a sequence of
actions and there's sort of rising
action and it's culminating in something
and you are in the middle of that
sequence of actions and you're about to
get to the culmination and I stopped it
and it's frustrating and you really want
to know what happens next and you would
never if you were listening to this have
turned off that podcast or that radio
story at that moment and that is a good
story and that's why you want to operate
in stories that's why you when you're
interviewing people you want to get
their stories out of them and you want
to get them talking in stories because
stories are what we want to hear
if you enjoyed this episode you are
going to love what I have coming all
sorts of crazy experiments incredible
guests and you can very easily not miss
any of it just subscribe on iTunes or
you can check out all of my guests as
well as my blog that has 1 to 2 million
readers per month at 4-hour workweek
comm all spelled out for our work week
calm that's where I Chronicle all of my
insane self experimentation and I would
love to hear from you so please reach
out to me on Twitter twitter.com /t
Ferriss TF e RR ISS or on facebook at
facebook.com/ forward slash Tim Ferriss
with two hours and two S's of course and
until next time thank you so much for
listening